les combats font rage
de nuit comme de jour l'armée russe
avance inexorablement vers Kiev comme en
témoigne ses hélicoptères filmés par un
habitant près de l'aéroport militaire de
costaud Mel selon volodies qui des
groupes Russes se seraient même
introduits dans la capitale
selon le président ukrainien plus de 137
personnes sont mortes dont la majorité
serait des civils malgré les messages de
soutien de la communauté internationale
volody mercedeski pointent par ailleurs
du doigt le manque d'aide de ses alliés
sur le terrain pour ralentir l'avancée
russe il a ainsi signé un décret à plomb
à la mobilisation générale mais face au
combat de nombreux habitants ont pris la
décision de fuir vers les pays voisins
on est parti à 2 semaines de ça on a
déménagé à vivre justement pour que ce
soit moins dangereux
parce que selon le Haut Commissariat au
réfugiés de l'ONU près de 100000
personnes ont ainsi quitté leur foyer
nombreux sont ceux à avoir trouvé refuge
dans le métro ukrainien pour se protéger
d'éventuelles bombardements